say you're at the beach and you get sand
in your eyes how do you know the sand is
there you obviously can't see it but if
you are a normal healthy human you can
feel it that sensation of extreme
discomfort also known as pain now pain
makes you do something in this case
rinse your eyes until the sand is gone
and how do you know the sand is gone
exactly because there's no more pain
there are people who don't feel pain now
that might sound cool but it's not if
you can't feel pain you could get hurt
or even hurt yourself
and never know it pain is your body's
early warning system that protects you
from the world around you and from
yourself as we grow we install pain
detectors in most areas of our body
these detectors are specialized nerve
cells called nociceptors that stretch
from your spinal cord to your skin your
muscles your joints your teeth and some
of your internal organs just like all
nerve cells they conduct electrical
signals sending information from
wherever they're located back to your
brain but unlike other nerve cells
nociceptors only fire if something
happens that could cause or is causing
damage so gently touch the tip of a
needle you'll feel the metal and those
are your regular nerve cells but you
won't feel any pain now the harder you
push against the needle the closer you
get to the no susceptor threshold push
hard enough and you'll cross that
threshold and the nociceptors fire
telling your body to stop doing whatever
you're doing but the pain threshold
isn't set in stone certain chemicals can
tune nociceptors lowering their
threshold for pain and when cells are
damaged they and other nearby cells
start producing these tuning chemicals
like crazy lowering the nociceptors
threshold to the point where just touch
can cause pain and this is where
over-the-counter pain killers come in
aspirin and ibuprofen block production
of one class of these tuning chemicals
called prostaglandins let's take a look
at how they do that when cells are
damaged they release a chemical called
arachidonic acid now two enzymes called
cox-1 and cox-2 convert this arachidonic
acid into prostaglandin h2 which is then
converted
to a bunch of other chemicals that do a
bunch of things including raise your
body temperature cause inflammation and
lower the pain threshold
now all enzymes have an active site
that's the place in the enzyme where the
reaction happens the active sites of
cox-1 and cox-2 fit arachidonic acid
very cozily as you can see there's no
room to spare now it's in this active
site that aspirin and ibuprofen do their
work so they work differently aspirin
acts like a spine from a porcupine it
enters the active site and then breaks
off leaving half of itself in there
totally blocking that channel and making
it impossible for the arachidonic acid
to fit this permanently deactivates
cox-1 and cox-2 ibuprofen on the other
hand enters the active site but doesn't
break apart or change the enzyme cox-1
and cox-2 are free to spit it out again
but for the time that that ibuprofen is
in there the enzyme can't bind our
academic acid and can't do its normal
chemistry but how do aspirin and
ibuprofen know where the pain is
well they don't once the drugs are in
your bloodstream they're carried
throughout your body and they go to
painful areas just the same as normal
ones so that's how aspirin and ibuprofen
work but there are other dimensions to
paint' neuropathic pain for example is
pain caused by damage to our nervous
system itself there doesn't need to be
any sort of outside stimulus and
scientists are discovering that the
brain controls how we respond to pain
signals for example how much pain you
feel can depend on whether you're paying
attention to the pain or even your mood
though pain is an area of active
research if we can understand it better
maybe we can help people manage it
better
you